[Music]
[Applause]
hi thank you for having me and thank you
for coming I'm super excited to talk to
you about everything Pete just stole my
thunder of you know anyways why is this
not clicking okay so I'm gonna tell you
a bit about how we've gotten to the
point that we've come considering all
the problems we have in our data
pipeline and our business problems so
without further ado this is the outline
that we're gonna go through right a bit
about our TR who we are what we do
problems we have a bit about our
analytics so how analytics and tech
works together to solve these problems
some evolution stuff so you know we
don't just we didn't just come up with
this we had to go through different
stages to be get to the point that we're
at and to influence the business and
then we'll talk a bit about Luigi so
sorry that's like a little further into
the talk so hold your horses and then
we're going to talk about what I have
planned for the future so first a bit
about art er who here has rented from
rent thrown away oh my gosh I think
there's more guys than girls I really
like that so um like Pete said you know
we rent dresses for a fraction of the
cost this is it's basically you
interface through it through a website
right so we can give you a gown we can
give you cocktail dresses jewelry and
now we can give you more like everyday
wear but we can only show you things
that are available for you so this
depends on three key pieces of
information right so we have to know
when your event is when you want your
dress what size you are and where you
are in the United States and this
determines availability of all of our
dresses we like to think of it as a way
that we can compete with a fast-fashion
price so you can swap things in and out
you don't have to worry about what is in
style because you're always going to be
in style if you rent with us right so
different
gowns we've also expanded
kind of our core business so now we have
rental or retail stores so you can come
to one of our stores try on all the
products and decide what works for you
what doesn't and you'll guaranteed to
have a wonderful event we've also
launched a subscription-based program so
this is more for jewelry and everyday
wear like jackets casual jewelry I guess
they call it fine jewelry and this means
that you can get three different pieces
for as long as you want you can swap
them in and out you can keep them as
long as you pay us for them so you know
the general model is like okay you see a
fabulous dress you want to wear it so we
provide access to that and this is the
value proposition is that we don't have
to pay for that whole dress that you may
only wear once and you only pay a
fraction of the retail cost generally
it's about 10% of the price but we'll
get into that later but then you never
have to wear the same thing twice you
don't have to have anything hanging out
in your closet and we make fashion
accessible so you may never wear an
Herve Leger but today you can in
practice we deal with reverse logistics
right we're dealing with humans we're
dealing with real inventory and this
creates lots of problems because humans
are error-prone right we're not just a
website or an online abstraction of our
products we have to barcode every single
product and we have to know where it is
at every single moment we have to know
when it's going to be available in the
future how far we can ship that for a
given person given when they want it
given other rentals around it and it's
just a huge optimization problem right
we have people that want things and we
have inventory and how do we match that
up accordingly and not only that we have
to you know like Pete said we have to
bring in the inventory from shipping we
have to be able to process it which
means we're doing QA we're dry cleaning
things we're racking them we're putting
them out for shipment again and this is
just like a lot of things that can go
wrong right things can get lost things
can get broken
and there's always going to be infinite
number of edge cases okay so the basic
motto that we live by is everything can
be solved through technology right we're
not going to scale just by people alone
or inventory alone or more people
looking at the problem we really need a
system that can understand all of the
moving components and it can do that
global optimization so what we really do
is just strive to focus on how data can
help us solve all of our problems so
this means that you know analytics and
engineering are really solving these
problems it's not just someone dictating
from on high telling us what we're
supposed to do we have to push for
everything being tracked and this is
really the reason that we've succeeded
we make data relevant to everyone so
people aren't just throwing features out
there we're telling them how those
features are relevant and how they
affect the customer because the big
optimization problem is really about
making sure that we're optimizing on
customer happiness and but we're getting
the most out of our dresses that we can
comments okay no questions so the way
that data gets surfaced is this goes to
executives as you would expect right we
do analytics we send reports out people
make business decisions based on those
we also create like when there's a we
see where there's places that we can
create value so there's something that's
taking too long there's something that
can be fixed analytics can tell you what
where those problems are and how to fix
them and then when you launch website
features we do the general of tracking
of every of all the metrics and
supporting those algorithms that power
all of the features so this huge
feedback loop right we're not just there
to give you numbers and throwing them
out there were in turns ik part of the
whole organization right so the general
structure I think about our engineering
platform is there's demand so there's
people coming to
website their features we're launching
there's people interacting with it
there's transactions that happen we have
to fulfill those and then on the other
side their supply right this is the
physical constraints that we have on our
system this is the number of inventory
this is how fast we can process address
and how long address is expected to last
and how do we tie individual dresses to
individual people is through something
called our reservation calendar which
will has a big part in and this is like
each of these services right or they're
not done in a specific way they can have
my sequel backends they could be
streaming and everything I have to do is
ingest all of that and make it
accessible to the rest of analytics so
for instance you're not supposed to just
like read this this is just to show you
how messy this system can be right so
these are all of our individual services
and I'm part of that data Liberation
Front that's gonna take all of those
back-end databases and make them
accessible for me and combine all the
data in as many ways as possible that
makes sense for example some of these
are purely data driven services so we
have a pixel log so we can track
everything that a user is doing on the
website we see what they're clicking on
what they're viewing and that's get
surfaced to us and we can combine it
with these tables we also have a service
called alchemy which is our experiment
service and using this combined with our
ability to flag features we can do a/b
testing so we can bucket users limit
users according to what device they're
on if they're logged in or anonymous and
I think at any given time we're running
between 10 and 20 experiments so that
Sun right sure will go with that
but that's just stuff that's enabling
analytics to do more with everything
that's going on some other cool things
we can do is we're actually showing
where analytics is in control of what
the user is seen on the front
so we have personalized recommendations
we can sort the addresses how we want
the customer to see them we can also
tell you how similar addresses are we
look at how often a user comes at back
look at your attributes of the dresses
what seasonality is doing to this and we
can say okay like people do
collaborative filtering and say like oh
people are buying these are renting
these necklaces with these outfits so we
can try to upsell you and tell you how
to accessorize your outfit the fine
print on this is that means that
production and engineering processes are
depending on us right they're giving us
the trust to actually influence what
people are doing and I didn't realize
this until I talked to other companies
but usually Analects is just someone
that's just like writing reports right
they're not actually having control on
what people are doing with the product
other places this shows up is we have a
demand forecast so we can look at how
how do we price a product such that we
ensure that a customer is happy right
we're not gonna price it too low such
that everyone wants the same dress and
we can't fulfill that and we're not
gonna price it so high that nobody wants
that dress others and then on the right
this is a representation of how we track
inventory so we know the whole lifecycle
of an individual unit and we can look at
for a given style and a given size how
does the number of units change over
time and how does that affect future
reservations so we can look at ups data
repair data and see you know try to tell
customers before they have a sad
experience with us that maybe they
should try another dress okay
so I think that's all pretty cool
hopefully you guys do too but we didn't
just get here you know right away we had
to grow into this so I like to think of
it in a few distinct phases right
there's phase zero where you're a
startup and you're like oh okay let's
just get things out there let's start
creating features we're outgrowing our
current needs what do we want for the
future
we don't know we're just going to see
put it all out there see what happens
and you know you're doing this is all
really fast you're just trying to stay
relevant and as an engineer you're just
like Yolo let's do this okay you know
we're just going to change data
structures we're gonna create new things
everything's in a different tool and
language all right so what this means
for an analyst is a little bit like this
right you're just overwhelmed you're
just trying to keep up with what
everyone else is doing so you're trying
to maintain cleanness and accuracy
you're rewriting business logic because
the engineers don't care about it
they're just trying to get something out
there and you know we're making the data
relevant to other people other than just
serving the website or running the
warehouse and this is good because as
analysts we like to hoard data so that
means that we have the best history we
have the longest history we have
everything right and we're all we're
really doing is trying to keep it
together keep it together and as an
analyst then this means that you have to
have some sense of data engineering you
have to know how to fetch the data
you're have to be able to access it no
matter how it's stored you may be
working off production tables maybe
copies of production tables and there's
no time to really invest in a process
right so what this look like for us is
just a bunch of random bash scripts
they're just everywhere
nobody cares or knows what they're doing
but somebody liked it enough to write it
but this creates a nice breeding ground
right for the primordial soup - like
coalesce and be like oh wait I see some
similarities do things between things
going on and you start to create modules
that can help you fetch easier you write
summary tables and you glue all of your
sequel together with PHP will
pearl pearl well both that's really the
best way to do that I'm pretty sure but
really you're just like removing that
monotony of running reports over and
over again maybe you can email them out
maybe you create a website to host data
and then at the same time as you're like
things look to be getting better
engineering is like hey you know what
you know how everything's written in
Drupal let's rewrite it into Java and
you're just like why would you create a
whole nother set of tables that now I
have to track and understand so you're
gonna have to duel right to everything
cool cool yeah so you know like this is
probably good because they're making a
deliberate decision and we can kind of
draw off those choices right so we can
be like oh like they see a future they
want to make this scalable how about we
do the same thing and this is where you
get to Phase two which is where we
started to create some semblance of a
pipeline so we created a well we we
bought Vertica right so we just dumped
everything in there we have one source
of truth we can do all of our ETL so we
can move data from my sequel into
Vertica from into Vertica we can
transform it to make it interesting for
everyone else like you know
understandable instead of like obscure
column names it actually makes sense and
at the same time we started rewriting
our framework into Python and some of
our requirements were while we're
growing as a company not everyone is a
data engineer so we need them to be able
to contribute to our pipeline so we need
this script to handle any type of
program it can be shell scripts Python
scripts perl PHP it can access any sort
of database and it doesn't have to be
something that someone has to learn and
to program right they don't want to do
that so for example a lot of our
processes come from replicated data
of in my sequel and then we pulled them
into Vertica because it's much faster in
Vertica and so we do this tighten this
nightly load and as an analyst you can
just go in and just be like oh just add
a new line to this config file and it's
great so a bit about this config file so
this is an example of one that controls
our order warehouse and all it says is
like there's a comment section there's
like okay what kind of program do I need
to run this with what is the file that I
need to run and then you just kind of
write them out like a recipe do one two
three four and the great part about this
is you don't have to know much other
than you know push and pull on git you
need to know sequel or how to write a
script which can be pretty easy and then
a little bit about the command line but
that's a pretty low bar right like most
people can figure out how to do five or
six commands so like when they want to
run it you're just like oh I'm gonna run
this job order warehouse right boom done
or you just want to be like I want to
see what all the steps are and then we
also have control into only doing
certain parts of that pipeline and the
meat and potatoes of this is it
basically shells out right so we have a
function that's just run process it
takes essentially the command and tries
to run that in a shell and catches
exceptions it does some logging it
retries given proprietary like errors
cuz we're on an old version of Vertica
so it tends to lose connections
willy-nilly so we can like be like oh
it's fine don't worry about it rerun it
we have alerting on this but it's really
simple super simple and I like it
and with this kind of framework we have
been able to keep up with engineering
right in one year like last year which
was a relatively slow year they tell me
they rewrote our entire commerce
services so they rewrote how we deal
with transactions we and how we deal
with order changes we've rewritten the
back end of inventory service so
we track the lifecycle of a unit that's
completely new we have our new
subscription-based service with new
inventory we launched retail stores
which meant understanding point-of-sale
systems and how to deal with
appointments and we've also added the
ability to change prices dynamically and
through like the great part about this
pipeline is that it shortens that
feedback loop so now that we have
alerting and monitoring on everything
and they're all going through the same
kind of process we can tell engineering
when things are going wrong or
unexpected so we're keeping them
reliable and not just finding these
errors when we decide to run a report
you know like let's say you want to run
a report on how many orders were getting
and you don't realize until three months
later that you're missing pixel
information on in orders it's never
happened to me okay then we get to where
I am now which is a pretty good place
right we've kind of caught up on
everything things are kind of working
but this is all about exposing
weaknesses right so we're adding more
alerting adding more monitoring finding
the quick wins on how we can make this a
faster and more efficient process what
is the dead things that we can just kill
that nobody really cares about anymore
and I really just like increasing
visibility into our platform I want
other people to get excited and to know
what we're working on so we can
communicate efficiently between
engineers and analysts right like there
shouldn't be this big divide not that
there ever is but like it can happen we
want them invested in what we're doing
also
but the biggest questions I have here is
how do we keep this engine running right
how do we keep doing this without having
me go in and rerun jobs how do I remove
the whole human part of this and while
we're still like expanding everything
that we want to do we want to add more
data we want to change how the data
looks so part of this is all about
flexibility we want to add dependencies
right so when one thing fails I don't
want to restart ten things in a specific
order and this is where we get to Luigi
so I'm assuming because you know we're
in Spotify so everyone knows what Luigi
is right we just get it by osmosis so
yeah okay cool so I'm not gonna go over
that
JK's okay so it's basically a dependency
manager that builds complex pipelines of
batch data right I like it because it's
written in Python which means that I can
extend it I can change it I can
troubleshoot it right
it already has built-in functionality to
work with batch and daily jobs which is
most of what our pipeline is and it
easily deals with failures so it will
automatically know when something's
failed it needs to rerun and there's
this whole chain of like things paused
until that the other thing is fixed I
also like it because I can integrate it
with our current system without having
to change any of the benefits right I
want to be able to put this in the
backend such that nobody knows that
Luigi is actually controlling what's
going on people can still contribute add
steps to all of their jobs and they
don't care right so really simply what
this looks like is we have our run job
before instead we can just extend one of
the Luigi tasks class such that it calls
that essentially right this is no
different than what we were doing before
it still just runs one step at a time
whatever but what we really want is it
to know about the whole chain of events
so instead we tell it okay we want to go
from step zero to step 100 and the way
to do this is through the requires
function so we overwrite that and we say
okay actually before you run step
hundred you need to run step 99 so we
just do this recursively that's pretty
cool and then we can like expand all of
our config files to call each other and
then we just have this big configuration
tree of what is going on I've also added
the ability to force a rerun which like
is something that happens for us when we
need to test something so we can just
like make Luigi forget that it ever runs
something today and then we can just run
it again
okay yeah so that's this Luigi what I
did but this is gonna set us up for the
future and of course there's always more
that we're gonna do and the future is to
become our data pipeline we are one with
it like we want to take ownership of
pixels we want to be even more
integrated with engineering like there's
not going to be a definition of
analytics and engineering we can make
this less reactionary and we need to
deal with scaling problems obviously
right do we want to do real-time how do
we deal with more data what happens when
we reach all of our capacity and it
takes 24 hours to run everything do we
want to do Hadoop I don't know but some
problems that we're facing right now are
before we get to the next step is how do
we deal with testing and QA and dev
environments because apparently that's a
really cool thing so you don't mess up
production data like we want to be able
to flexibly change code and change what
we're looking at and have reliable
hardware that doesn't take two days to
recover from and part of this is all
about removing that proprietary
information so we want everything into
the git repo right we don't want there
to be like someone being like oh wait I
know how the data gets there if you look
in blah blah blah over here it pulls
data XY and Z and you're just like well
that's that's great I'm glad somebody
knew that because nobody else knew what
was going on so it's all about making it
documented and intuitive for someone to
just get onboard quickly so like and
even non technically we need to get
engineers super excited about what we're
doing right we want them excited about
being data-driven and they don't just
release things into the wild without
being worried about how it's performing
and how it's impacting the business
because engineering is all about
impacting the business they're the ones
driving it they're controlling how some
we succeed or fail and of course we're
always better together than we are on
our own it's great
and begin a data-driven culture isn't
something that just you do once and then
you're always data-driven you have to
continually reinforce that just like a
big feedback loop and also making sure
our reports are reliable and people
trust what we're doing so most of that I
think is all about transparency and no
longer playing catch-up so like overall
you like there's this transformation of
your you're overwhelmed and crazy but
there's a turning point where you're
like oh wait I can look at the future
and I can see how we can build these
systems and how we can be reliable and
influence things better and maybe just
be a little faster
so in conclusion like I think we have
lots of cool problems and I feel like
these are problems that a lot of people
have but that there is no one good way
or that that people have found right
like we found a solution that works for
us but there's nothing out there
specifically that I found that was like
oh that's the wringer that's what's
gonna happen for us and we're given a
lot of autonomy to do what we want to do
right we can look at the complete
problem and make decisions we're given
the opportunity to make mistakes and to
think about the future and think about
the direction of analytics so we will
become one with computers
hopefully oh and we're hiring that's all
thank you
[Applause]
does anyone have questions yes
oh yeah so uh when you look at behavior
data of consumers who are making
purchases actually actually like a pain
consumers so do you like do you see a
lot about like a similar kind of a user
profile so like in terms of patterns and
just say they'll so hamat like roughly
like how many unlike different profiles
are there do you like a categorize
people by like a different user profiles
oh like for marketing purposes or for
assigning like what person should view
yeah so like so let's say a person makes
decision a and B and based on debt do
you make kind of a predictions as to
what person might like and give more
kind of suggestions yeah so part of our
recommendation system is personalized so
we correlate a person with what they're
looking at and then obviously what other
people are looking at those same dresses
we put that like within a three month
time frame so we say like okay we can
create similar users based on what kind
of attributes of those dresses that they
like hi
do you use click data so as far as click
data goes do you concentrate on users
that don't necessarily purchase anything
or focus your energy on helping people
that do purchase things can you be more
specific so if I'm a user and I don't
buy anything but my click data has given
you non-trivial amounts of information
Oh like retargeting them do you actively
retarget customers okay so we have we
are integrated with sale through so we
can tell them hey this person looked at
these dresses and we push them emails to
say like you should go back because they
may run out of that dress okay thanks
you mentioned I'd be testing with
alchemy is that your own custom solution
or yes so that's something that we wrote
using like a Adobe test and targeter
Optimizely or anything no we had a
system already in place before we had
thought of those solutions and so we
just made it more robust and accessible
for everyone to use
[Music]
you mentioned a Hadoop briefly have you
guys used Hadoop or spark or anything
like that in conjunction with Luigi and
I guess more generally like where do you
kick your jobs off to you like how is
that infrastructure set up so our jobs
are kicked off through cron really
simply yeah we do not use Hadoop
currently or SPARC but we're looking at
those as options for the future we
played around with storm a little bit
just to deal with our a B framework and
getting results right away but that
never made it to fruition so just
quickly do you not like you don't
encounter trouble with like the size of
the data or stuff it's still manageable
without it's still manageable at the
moment but we know that we're gonna have
problems so we're doing that
investigation now so you may have
touched on this I may have just missed
it but do you foresee kind of your data
collection going further upstream than
just Rent the Runway going actually to
the designers or at least distributor
kind of like maybe influenced or at
least kind of informed some of the
design decisions to say well we've seen
a lot of customers kind of like going
for these type of designs and things
like that and maybe kind of affecting
the industry as well yeah so when we
partner with designers we do give them
information about how well a dress is
performing so that includes like
different attributes and we can share
that with them but it's up to them
whether they want to abide by that and
you find they're receptive to that or is
that something that they're still like
what's this data thing that I'm seeing I
think it depends on the designer
obviously
so so like I think clover Canyon is a
good example of they have a very
reliable product that we have customers
respond well to and that survives the
product lifetime so like it can go
through a lot of customers before we
have to retire it and they're very
different from someone who like is
purely like mesh fabrics or lace which
can deteriorate but that also depends on
our buying decisions before the talked
it was mentioned that like you know what
if there's a blizzard or a storm in a
certain city then you guys have to be
prepared to handle orders that are
affected by that use like any
statistical models or like how do you go
about ensuring that somebody gets the
right thing or close to the right thing
in time and then you get it back in time
so the reservation calendar is like the
brains behind everything so that
determines what someone can rent so if
they if a customer runs something for a
specific time and it ends up not being
possible due to a storm like we have to
tell them like it for a storm you can't
really do anything right we can't ship
it out but we don't take in information
about whether beforehand what do you
want
I think it's a very messy question yeah
he can tell you how about kids why kids
kids like children's clothing yeah
teenage against I think we haven't done
that yet
but I think there has to be time to
figure out if there's a market for
people yeah prom dresses that's close
we're asking about all the market trade
secrets of runs runway I know nothing
anyone else oh my god hi sorry I was
just curious about sort of the the
sizing of the data sets the number of
events the types of events and then also
what sort of tools your data scientists
are using okay the second one is easier
so right now there is no strict rule
about what kind of language they can use
so there's everything from R to Python
Java and Scala in production that we
have contributed to the second question
about what events you look at mostly
everything so anytime you click on the
website so this can be like the basic
funnel is you show up on Oh Webster
website you go to address page you enter
in your zip code and your size you open
up the calendar to see what dresses like
what dates are available you click one
you add it to cart and then there's all
the information related to specific and
experiments so like what is being popped
up what our people click are they
responding to like the right hand rail
of like past few dresses so does that
help
okay sorry so you sort of create these
models that are you know the core of
your business is the ability to predict
the future with all the sort of
messiness and of course you have
confidence intervals I guess I was
curious like how do your data scientists
validate that the predictive models are
healthy and sort of accurate I mean we
do like bootstrapping and I think
there's some tenfold validation in there
but I mean we work on past data before
we go looking at the future or we run
experiments until we get enough data to
say like oh yeah that agreed with our
hypothesis or it didn't hi
so I thought I heard you guys mentioned
that you really aren't using to do
really so how are you doing with stuff
that like you know isn't necessarily
just like a select from Vertica but like
you know larger data that you want to
put together is it just like one machine
you're just you know brute forcing it or
what excusing for most of the like
Vertica is is like a cluster right so we
usually stick everything in Vertica that
we ever want to analyze because it has
the power behind it so if it's in like
some JSON format we try to try to make
it into something that's relational and
then stick it in there if you want to do
like collaborative filtering right you
you could maybe like write some custom
vertical plugins or something but well
I'm doing something that was like you
know isn't necessarily just like a
sequel selector crunching or some
summarization yeah our has the ability
to plug into Vertica also so it can take
a handle of that someone else I think in
the back I can't see oh here we go
Thanks
hi so you mentioned that you write
reports for executives but you also some
data to the engineering teams you talk a
little bit about what you gave to
engineering teams we give dashboards to
give reports to just go over and talk to
them yes all of those things I would say
there's kind of two main pipelines of
how we send data back for surface to the
website or for the business one of them
are like daily batch jobs that then we
give them CSVs in a certain format and
they consume those other ways are we we
actually write with the right production
code with them so those are like Scala
and Java problems where we're like we're
writing fulfilment and then we're taking
in all of the data that they're getting
in that way but we're handling the
algorithms anyone else so in the
reservation calendar are you planning on
sort of coming up with likelihood
estimators of transactions taking place
on on time and things like that so we
know that we do like demand forecasting
and just like understanding how
reservations build up over time we can
take a look at a specific dress on a
specific weekend because the way that
people rent is usually the best we can
do is one dress out per week right so
it's kind of a weekly cycle so if we
focus on a weekend we can see how
reservations build up over time and
that's kind of an oh god an exponential
write growth so it's like two weeks out
we get probably 50% of our reservations
and then 50% the next two weeks oh gosh
what was your question do you plan on
coming up with likelihood estimators of
transactions you know taking place
successfully right right so from that
like if once
get out two weeks out right we kind of
have enough reservation such that we can
predict where we're gonna end up on the
number of reservations given that price
but yeah there is some obviously some
flexibility in that all right great
thank you wanna give her hand again
[Applause]